and then he's talking to her and I just
run up to him and I'm just waiting and I
guess I just [ __ ] socked him
in the face she got knocked out for sure
dude and then what happened and then
what happened they took him home so I'm
gonna start blowing the guy [ __ ] wait
wait the glimp the glimpse of glimp
[Music]
so there was a uh and this is one of
those we've almost all been there before
let's see how we all relate there was a
naked British man who was found on a
Thai beach after a massive party with no
recollection of the last two days this
sounds like a hangover it really does
actually everybody is comparing this to
The Hangover I just think it's funny
that you've got this photo right here
are they party hard dude it sounds like
my second quinceanera
sitting along the beach is just staring
at the ocean you know what the [ __ ]
happened I don't mind TJ
he's all butt naked so yeah just like
the hangover this guy was discovered on
a Thai beach with no memory of what
happened after two days the unidentified
man who is age 30 from Epsom Surrey is
somewhere in the UK I believe has been
celebrating his birthday with beer and
marijuana on a session that began on the
27th of October he was discovered two
days later by stunned locals in Koh
Samui stumbling around and singing
football songs before beer and marijuana
I think I think that's what
he's probably doing more [ __ ] yeah he
was in the country for a wedding and was
traveling on a tourist visa and while
the a fisherman attempted to help the
man when he was in the water he
allegedly became aggressive and screamed
that he wanted to go and meet with God
nobody believed it was just things like
beer and marijuana so they do a drug
test on him and it's negative there's no
drugs really no drugs uh despite his
protest the fisherman was able to save
him by pulling the man because he's
schizophrenic
people are just saying maybe it's like
like the dehydration from partying and
like the Sun but he gets a little cuckoo
or whatever like that he gets hot sweats
low tolerance yeah I'm pretty sure
that's what it was but regardless it did
inspire me to think about maybe some of
the times that we've kind of had those
kind of Benders you said it reminds you
of your second quinceanera you got two
Quinceaneras I mean I got invited to
Quinceaneras
you're not getting together yes you get
them all the time right yeah for sure is
there a big celebration for dudes yeah
no of course I thought they're called
quinceaneros oh here we go and there's a
masculino
so in the Filipinos have this thing
called the debut right a debut yeah for
for girls it's like quinceanero
so he he he's such a [ __ ] troll he
begged his dad to have one and he's like
[ __ ] man he goes all right so for his
for his 15th birthday he got to have one
and then I think it's 16 for the
Philadelphia yeah 16 but but he wanted
to wear a suit and do a whole birthday
thing and the whole day was a big troll
oh that's that well that you know that
sounds like fun so yeah you look like a
guy who's been [ __ ] up before though
like oh dude tell us a [ __ ] up story
uh yeah I mean I have a bunch like I'm
Latino we you know I mean we started
drinking at [ __ ] 10 we're like [ __ ]
so I have [ __ ] up stories for days but
tell us a story when you were 10. when I
was 10 dude I remember when we were 10
we would Jack our parents beer that's
the thing we were jacking will go and
the corner we'll drink it and stuff yeah
and uh who's we my cousins you mean my
cousins would just like get [ __ ] up
and then I remember the first time I got
[ __ ] up I I had like a 40 but in
Mexico they call it kawamas
yeah so then Malt Liquor they uh no dude
it was just like a it's not like a 40
it's like a it's just like it's not like
a big old yeah it's not like an actual
[ __ ] 40 but to them it's like a kind
of let's go anyways but I remember the
first time I got [ __ ] up I remember
they opened it up my cousin's endurance
was like chug it I've never chugged but
I tried to impress them because that's
some girls there and I was like I'm
looking in the corner of the girls
looking at me yeah they're they're
rolling over here
right and then I was almost halfway all
right I did it and they put it away and
then I was like and they're like my
cousin tells me in 15 minutes you're
gonna get [ __ ] up and I was like all
right like when is this gonna happen
I've never been drunk before so I'm like
what is this gonna happen what's gonna
what's going on and then suddenly you
just start everything starts feeling
heavy and and you know your eyes are
just what that's your first time getting
drunk first time getting drunk and I
remember going like whoa and I remember
feeling like a kid like just childish
and you were a kid and I felt more like
a kid where I just felt like Invincible
I remember I started running on the
street because I remember thinking like
I can't feel my legs and I feel like I'm
running really fast I can run really
fast without getting tired because I'm
not feeling my legs so then I just
thought it and I just everybody's in
conversation I'm just like [ __ ] we're
almost there running like what the [ __ ]
happened though he's living Wall Street
kid [ __ ] you know yeah like I was doing
like kid [ __ ] you know like run running
around in circles and you know just
[ __ ] climbing on [ __ ] jumping and not
hurting seeing if it hurts kid [ __ ] yo
that's what happens when kids get drunk
yes and uh and yeah then I remember just
being like [ __ ] drunk and being young
doesn't has there ever been in time as a
drugstore where you just woke up like
this dude where you just don't remember
like you blacked out
yeah I do remember I don't know if is
this patreon nah no just keep it real
dude just just censor some stuff I mean
yeah censor the details you want I
remember because I remember I was at the
club and I remember taking a shot and
then I remember talking to this girl and
then I remember just taking shots and
shots and then suddenly we just drink
the tequila bottle like that at the club
and everything was cool and I remember
just moments of of with her in the
restroom and then like little when I go
back and then a guy punching me and I'm
like getting punched and I go back and
I'm at a taco stand and I'm like
throwing up and then I go back to the
club and then I punched a guy and I
remember just like about fight breaks
down different guy different guy no the
same guy same guy so what happens
apparently what happened
yo so apparently what happened is that
they I [ __ ] got [ __ ] up and I was
talking to the guy's girl and then the
guy was like what the [ __ ] is the rest
you're making out and then he [ __ ]
gets me punches me and I [ __ ] get
thrown out and then you got Rumble but
he stayed and then I got thrown out and
I was just pissed and walking around and
I ate a taco and in my head I'm just
thinking like you know what I'm gonna
[ __ ] this fool up so I snuck back in the
club he was making out with her yeah
after and then he's talking to her and I
just run up to him and I'm just waiting
and I guess I just [ __ ] socked him
in the face she got knocked out for sure
dude and then what happened and then
what happened he took him home so I'm
gonna start blowing the guy [ __ ] wait
wait wait
and then back to Tacos
[ __ ] Butterfly Effect I've ever had
in my [ __ ] life it was all over the
place man I just remember like showing
up to an ex-girlfriend's house and I was
there and he's saying sorry yeah I snuck
in a room and I just [ __ ] you know
and I woke up like what the [ __ ] just
happened that sounds like a good night
that was a crazy like night that's legit
but that's the thing when I get drunk I
get very like aggressive like the
machista Mexican [ __ ] comes out you need
multa yeah no is the worst for me you
get more rest
I start thinking about life why am I
here Spanish why are we here really
what's going on what is this it's like
does everybody not acknowledge the fact
that we're like human what is what's
going on I think yeah we're just
acknowledging it dude the fact that we
all work and have jobs and I'm like why
why are we here we have an existential
crisis sometimes you need that though
what's that what's that exponential what
exactly what you just explained together
questioning your life Your Existence am
I gay huh yeah well yeah maybe maybe I
do I do question everything so when you
know these are still good questions even
sober for sure I should just have more
of those yeah we should just think about
it a little more often crises
existential that's pretty cool no
getting high nah dude I I start tripping
out you done other drugs no that's it
the weed is like I can only handle weed
and that's it like so do you when you
drink do you are you more likely to get
into a fight with somebody yes have you
do you have any good fight stories you
uh I have all my life fight stories dude
yeah my life was [ __ ] you know what
it is I'm that I was that guy that was
like you talk [ __ ] to me like you'll say
something like hey what y'all dude what
the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] you say so in my head I'm
like all right so then I'm drinking and
you for you're in the [ __ ] bar you're
like oh it's your friend I'm watching
like I can't feel my legs I'm still like
I want revenge for that little moment
that just happened like I'm looking for
Revenge so I'm just like waiting and
then two in the morning I just [ __ ]
just boom like what the [ __ ] happened
I'm just [ __ ] fighting everybody now
you watch out for that yeah
bleeding everybody's bleeding just
because of the [ __ ] hey watch out
dude that's all it was but in my drawing
he should have been nicer though he
disrespected homie you don't disrespect
like that's just better that's my
parents [ __ ] disrespective and I'm
taking out on this guy
any therapy and [ __ ] yeah
and it probably was that it probably
wasn't in my head escalated it in my
head I heard [ __ ] with y'all you
stupid never gonna be nobody that's what
I heard
that's what I heard but all he said was
like hey what y'all dude you're gonna
fall yeah you're gonna fall yeah yeah
dude watch out dude and I'm like hey he
should have watched out though you don't
know me Dad it's like what yeah
so I have a lot of problems as to how to
work out yeah I went out you should go
fight with Nick he he helps work out a
lot of aggression oh dude I will look
too my gym yeah it's called Lionheart
Jiu Jitsu Academy oh dude I'm sure dude
I'm trying to get into Jiu Jitsu a
little bit my guy dude I just did it
recently and I was like it's her Academy
her last name is Lionheart [ __ ] yeah
dude I'm down really helps you deal with
yourself literally literally I was like
two days ago I was looking up like
[ __ ] spots on my dad yeah we will
work out those those traumas thank you
yeah you get to beat the [ __ ] out of
each other you know feel better you know
yeah I'll put you with Nick he's one of
my top guys and we'll work it out yeah
he's a top guy I like him yeah not
really I'm more like a bottle oh yeah
I'm more of a bottom yeah I'll sit on my
butt and everything dude yeah dude he
works both ways though he's pretty good
but yeah we should go drinking sometime
yeah no I
put the problems are calm
try to fight calm comic like which ones
any famous ones
no no let's talk about it that was just
like Comics I would just try to fight
all the time I was on the road are they
[ __ ] though they're being dicks
though it was me any comments if I could
punch a comic yeah oh [ __ ]
uh which comic could I ah I don't know
which which comic would I [ __ ]
Russell Peter no he's cool I don't have
nobody that Bobby Lee Chris Sosa
christosa he's pretty punchable yeah I
don't know if there's a comic that I
wish I could punch Jason Cheney you know
Jason I love Jason Cheney I'll punch him
for sure dude and he'd be like oh that's
so nice
oh wow you just punched me why yes
that's good Jason is [ __ ] hilarious
this is my one of my good friends dude
there it is and we're gonna punch you
Jason yeah when I see you dude just know
it just know where he came from dude
yeah
foreign